our final panel today is called the pol
six of hate and we have three riveting
panelists that I'll briefly introduce
and then I'll let them take the mic to
begin we have dr. Bob piercing
she's a postdoctoral fellow at the
University of Texas in Austin and the
woman's gender and sexuality studies her
first book is called militant bodies and
it will look at the visual culture and
body politics of Muslim and Sikhs under
the rise of global astana phobia
her latest essay is titled the commodity
fetish of modest fashion and it's coming
out this October and QED a journal of
GLBTQ world-making after her we'll have
dr. Algernon Austin he's currently an
economist at demos previously he was the
director of the program on race
ethnicity and economy at the Economic
Policy Institute and he researches
racial inequality and racial ideology
and identity his most recent book is
titled America is not post-racial
xenophobia Islamophobia racism and the
44th president so I want to thank our
speakers today and we'll begin with dr.
Barbara Singh and her paper is called
the quotidian violence of Islamophobia
Hey hi everybody I just want to start by
thinking and I'm Steeve as well as my
short I just wouldn't
okay this good yeah thanks to Steve
Maurice
Nandi and Anessa for organizing
conference five years ago on August 5th
2012 Wade Michael Page opened fire in a
Sikh Gurdwara in Oak Creek Wisconsin
killing six and wounding three members
of the congregation before killing
himself while Oak Creek can be read as a
tragedy holy unto itself
it discursive Lee served as a way of
crystallizing certain racial and
political paradigms in a post-911 world
it reminded six Muslims and other South
and West Asian diasporic subjects that
racist violence marks their very
existence and that despite the
specificity of their differences theirs
was a set of populations materialized as
a singular threat to national security
and the greater goals of Western
Imperial projects Oak Creek symbolically
represents both an exceptional moment of
violence where six in sacred space were
targeted as well as a moment that
follows the logic of routine racist
violence that has emerged since 9/11
what is striking about Oak Creek was how
the murderous rampage of Wade Michael
Page was conducted alone in silence
logic seemingly unknown members of the
congregation noted that page did not say
a word the entire time of the attack
from the parking lot to the shootout
with lieutenant Brian Murphy during
which page was shot several times and
ultimately died of a self-inflicted
gunshot wound it is the scene of quiet
massacre that is perhaps most troubling
especially as a scene of racial violence
for example the quiet terror of women
hiding and huddled
in the gurdwaras kitchen pantry only to
be broken in the assurances of pages
debt highlighting the sense of rupture
and not simply feelings of security but
of sacred space the attack was quickly
rendered within the milieu of other
scenes of gun violence and mass
shootings in 2012 Buick Colorado movie
theater shootings happened about two
weeks prior the Sandy Hook school
shootings happened four months later the
attack was wedged between these events
and was swept up in the debate on gun
control and stricter background checks
discursively this altered the
examination of the event in narratives
on post 9/11 violence and death and
pushed it into other narratives around
gun control and mental health as though
these issues are unrelated the logic
became such that Paige was alone in his
attack with no accomplices or
conspirators that he must be understood
as a troubled madman his storied past
with the military and subsequent tales
of racial holy war to the few friends he
had aid in our reading of him as
isolated in his ideological ties still
this rationale was a narrative trap as
scholar and newcomer Perry argues quote
it might just be the case that
understanding our response to Oak Creek
has as much if not more to do with our
relationship to the shooter Wade Michael
Page as it does with the victims in
today's America as counterintuitive as
it sounds it's much more likely that the
public would come to identify with the
sikh victims than with paige and this
precisely is is what is at issue it's
the treatment of Paige as in a sense
foreign that disallows us from seeing
Oak Creek for what it is and this
analysis is directing readers to the
crucial legacy of racism and racial
violence in the u.s. that is deeply
embedded and indebted to structures of
white supremacy as he points out the
mainstream media's response was
predictably laden with narratives
five six as American as having roots in
the US since the early 20th century the
efforts to provide answers to questions
about who six are what they believe and
why they might have been attacked seemed
to be the only relevant form of
reporting for most news outlets when
Paige's identity was released and
details of his background as
dishonorably discharged from the US
military along with his participation in
neo-nazi culture and white supremacist
rock bands the morning following the
attack the portrait had been quickly and
hastily rendered as that of a figure
with whom we could decide enta fie that
is to say that the majority of Americans
could comfortably disavow any connection
to page as a normative citizen subject
seeking comfort in identifying with the
Sikh victims as as victims of an
American tragedy
one might say this disavowal is no
longer possible given that white
supremacy now comprises the American
executive branch even still such
designations of citizenship are always
in flux for the racialized physics
subject and I argue that there is
something yet to be articulated about
convergence of violence race and I'm
higher on this body what is to be said
is not exclusively the singularity of
this sick body but the constant
negotiation of it within configurations
of the brown body as enemy on the
evening of the attack on the oak creek
were Laura President Obama sent his
condolences to the families of the Oak
Creek victims naming them and six more
generally as part of our broader
American family and put that six at
edgren Laura can only be read as parts
of a broader America speaks volumes it
speaks to the strangeness of turbaned
bodies to their rendering in the visual
calculus of the war on terror it speaks
to the ways in which six have been and
continue to be distinctly and
ambiguously racialized globally
specifically under Islamic obeah as
imperial project to be clear I use the
term Islamophobia rather than
anti-muslim racism exclusively to
capture the ways in which the literal
fear of Islam and it's alleged
affinities manifests in wildly different
ways affecting various bodies and
communities since 9/11 six along with
Muslims have been repeated targets for
violence the first victim of this
violence was a middle-aged Sikh man
Balbir Singh Sodhi who was shot and
killed at his Mesa Arizona gas station
on September 15 2001 by Frank rope who
clearly carried through with his promise
of quote going out to shoot some
towelheads
after watching coverage of the 9/11
attacks mystic coalition estimates that
there have been over 700 cases of
violence against six since 9/11 and
stick targets of hate or racist violence
have tended to be male wear the turban
has remained the centerpiece in another
example in Federal Way Washington just
outside of Seattle on October 17 2012 a
passenger of a cab driven by a Sikh male
viciously attacked the cab driver after
commenting on the man's turban
proceeding to assault him tearing chunks
of his beard and subsequently loosening
one of the drivers teeth the Seattle
post-intelligencer reported that
according to the police the perpetrator
continued to make quote bigoted comments
about the cab driver continually
referring to him as Iraqi or Iranian
before making several anti-arab and
anti-gay slurs and quote
this attack helps communicate the depths
and ongoing nature of anti-sikh racism
and the Islamic and homophobic rhetoric
that goes hand-in-hand with such acts of
violence more pointedly the drive to
disaggregate the sick body in such a way
as to make it wholly unlike the Muslim
body the perilous body is to disentangle
and differentiate and to make real the
possibility that violence against most
is not just permissible but logical in
this context to desire coherence with
the mainstream is to disavow how racism
operates as well as how racist violence
erupts through forms and structures that
appear ordered and sensible if page was
in fact targeting six in Oak Creek in an
attempt to recognize them as part of
what Vijay Prashad calls a community of
outsiders then the recognitions of six
as foreign racialized and unassimilable
only serves to render them as at once
perilous and imperiled bodies for Paige
the Oak Creek or Loras communities very
gathering is an act of defiance against
white supremacist structures their
religious practice and their presence as
a congregation has rendered them as a
target and opportunity to violate and
harm many for page six represent a
violent dissonance or incoherence with
white America and might be then read in
militant opposition to current
majoritarian politics and to the
Islamophobic ideologies of the right
pages violence constitutes acts of
vigilantism as vigilantes operate
outside of the law vigilantes attempt to
become the sovereign to become the micro
state where the state appears to fail
them where legal apparatus is bar them
this space is where vigilantism is born
and out of which births violence and
death his method of attack echoes and
harkens us both backward and forward
historically now we have Paige now we
have the self-appointed neighborhood
watchman now we have the unhooded white
man of contemporary neo nazism in
Charlottesville now we have the rapid
radicalization of the right in all
corners of the internet now we have the
borders reinvigorated Wars in the clamp
down on
and right now we have the negation of
neoliberal multiculturalist tolerance
now we have the rise of unabashed anti
blackness and xenophobia that
constitutes the shameless white
supremacy of the u.s. settler state but
let us not be mistaken that this problem
is only American as we see this manifest
globally surely an asymmetrical but
similarly brutal ways in places
including Burma in many European
countries in occupied Palestine in South
Asia in the ongoing occupations of Iraq
Afghanistan and on and on broadly
speaking I want to ask what does it mean
to name Islamophobic violence as
quotidian how can we see violence
against Muslims and those presumed
Muslims and when I say this I mean to
say Brown enough I mean to say turban
wearing enough I mean to say beard
enough hijab wearing enough garb enough
generally foreign enough it's part of a
global everyday reality how can we
understand Islamophobic violence as
racial violence how is this racial
violence rooted in global right-wing
ideologies I use the examples of Wade
Michael pages 2012 rampage at the Oak
Creek Birth whare as a mode of thinking
about Islamophobic violence as racial
violence and always already tied to
white supremacist ideologies while Paige
himself is part of supposed fringe white
supremacist groups and bands we must
start to reckon with the ways in which
this fringe ness has never truly been
fringe rather that Paige's participation
points to the more recent consolidation
of and investment in white nationalist
power
moreover the trend of Islamophobic
violence targeting non-muslims in
addition to Muslims gives us a sense of
the ways this kind of violence is
necessarily reductive and unconcerned
with actual ties to Islam or any radical
political affinities instead some phobic
violence takes too
how visible minority Rhian identity is
collapsible and foldable into the
terrain of terrorized subjectivity under
21st century paradigms of racial
violence significant to the domain of
this violence and harm disappear poor
has outlined the processes of this form
of racial profiling in a chapter of
terrorist assemblages specifically
devoted to the bodily comportment of the
turbid Sikh reading the turban is a
queer signifier that accrued the
monstrous marks of terrorist masculinity
and finding in such an object a
counterpart to veils pores analysis
unpacks and rightly critiques the
Islamophobic mistaken identity narrative
pushed by some six civil rights
organizations earlier in the ongoing
global wars on terror I use this
argument as a point of departure when I
take up these comparative analyses of
hijab and turban and gendered and
racialized Muslim and Sikh identity
broadly in my book manuscript in
progress militant bodies violence and
visual culture under Islamic obeah I
take up the vital work of relational
materialist analysis as a means of
squarely focusing on the ongoing and
recent effects of Islamophobia under
American Empire I Center a visual
material cultural FM era and the
politics of dress and bodily comportment
that have manifested more recently to
show how both Muslims and six have been
rendered structurally vulnerable by the
state and civil society studying
contemporary paradigms of racial
violence in my case Islamophobic
violence that intersects with the realms
of anti-immigrant discourse anti
blackness misogyny and xenophobia has
always been weighed with immense
political stakes and urgency this
urgency has never been more clearly felt
than in the last year the election of
Donald Trump in the 2016 US presidential
race sent a clear message that quickly
emboldened those ready to act on their
simmering racist homophobic misogynist
and
but urges according to the Southern
Poverty Law Center there are over one
thousand ninety four bias related
incidents between November 9th and
December 12th according to the SPL C's
data these incidents are reported to be
anti-immigrant anti black anti-muslim
anti LGBT or anti women in this order
specifically examining the post-election
climate through social media the SPLC
published a report titled anti-muslim
sentiment dominated extremists Twitter
accounts
following the election wherein they
linked this attack on political
correctness to the emergence of a large
number of hate incidents targeting
Muslims Islam phobic targeting
harassment and harm is certainly not new
insofar as it often ignores the long
history of Black Muslim America but
appears as contemporary through the
politically charged climate following
the attacks on September 11th 2001 and
the ongoing violence wrought by the
global wars on terror resulting in
widespread harassment violence and death
targeting Muslims and Muslim adjacent
populations still worth noting however
is that in the wake of the recent
elections hate incidents and crimes rose
to levels even higher than after 9/11
this fact may certainly be due to the
wide swath of targets that Trump
supporters were animated to act against
most notably however were a string of
Islamophobic incidents targeting Muslim
women who wear hijab based on the
intersecting prejudices of those
harassing harming and violating these
incidents often occurred in public
spaces and as minor spectacles on city
streets public buses and metros and on
college campuses are costing us the
level of intimidation in terror very but
they reveal a renewed affront to Muslims
and
some women in particular setting a
frightening precedent for the years to
come the potential for Muslim registry
and the recent illegal ban on those
coming from Muslim majority countries
furthermore have set into motion state
sanction exclusion that propels the
enactment of public and vigilante forms
of violation and violence
most recently incidents in May 2017 in
Portland Oregon and in June 2017 in
Sterling Virginia have been notable
examples of Isana phobic violence in
Portland 35 year-old white nationalist
Jeremy Joseph Christian stabbed and
killed two men and injured another all
white for intervening in his racist
verbal assault of two teen girls one
black and one hijab' Muslim on a light
rail in sterling 22 year old Darwin
Martinez Torres attacked 17 year old
Egyptian American Abra Hassanein with a
baseball bat later abducting assaulting
and killing her at a nearby pond no
burrows death was particularly
horrifying as it came at the end of
Ramadan taking place after a group of
over a dozen all Muslim female friends
many wearing hijab and abaya including
no bruh we're leaving the all Dulles
area Muslim society Center mosque to get
food from a local fast food restaurant
late at night on June 17th 2017 and what
police are now calling a road rage
incident
tourists had gotten in an argument with
one of the members of the group as he
was driving and ended up exiting his car
with a baseball bat the group of friends
scattered to escape Torres's attack
though no bro was not able to get away
at this time her death is not being
ruled a hate crime which Muslim civil
rights groups understand is particularly
misguided moreover there is an ongoing
investigation into whether she was
sexually assaulted by tourists buyer
toward that the social media campaign
justice for nubra and the many vigils
and Memorial events held following her
death in late June 2017 have shown the
wide reverberations her brutal murder
had on Muslims living in the US as well
as on those consciously against
Islamophobia and its ceaseless violence
these incidents are further evidence on
the ongoing violence and death
of various racialized and gendered
bodies an acceleration in the forms and
expressions of Islamophobia misogyny
racism and masculine rage as they
consolidate under regimes of white
nationalism and imperialism a clear
cornerstone of the global rise of the
global right we see these eruptions of
racial violence in the context and surge
of acts of what appear senseless and
random as in cases of mass shooting by
the troubled individual in the
intersections of transients and mental
illness in road rage and misogyny
however this gesture to continually
render these violent acts as
individuated and disconnected or only
connected through senselessness is to
undermine and disavow the connection
they have to racism white supremacy and
production of bio political security
apparatuses
under Empire they are not senseless and
they are not random and in this scheme
an enemy does exist
well this enemy may or may not change
over time the contemporary period ropes
us into asking who is not the enemy its
opposite question exists to are there
any more friends in affirming the
pretense that these multiplying and
ceaseless examples of brutal violence
are not tethered to the ideology
ideological illness of white supremacy
we dishonor the dead in not tying the
death of number
Isana to racial violence in denying that
hate and racism still fueled her death
simply because other factors were at
play is to only buy into the logic that
these events of violence and death occur
in a vacuum we own umbra more and in
pursuing justice in the wake of her
death we must think intersectionally
about black Muslim life about the
feminist choice to wear hijab about the
gathering of young visibly Muslim girls
together during Ramadan breaking fast
naming the sites of Islamophobic
violence within the current era of
proliferating brutality and violence
against minority Rhian bodies want to
place emphasis on how to best practice
solidarity a lie ship and care for those
bodies and communities if we take what
black feminist theorist Christina sharp
and cedilla Hartman recently stated to
heart that quote care is the antidote to
violence and quote then we must practice
care anew in how we act in the face of
ongoing and debilitating violence
against Muslims ik Arab black Asian
Latino transgender differently-abled
queer brown and immigrant bodies we must
invest in new heightened and deeper care
in our fight against fascism both in the
US and the world over thank
[Music]
Thank You Belle Pierre next we have a
dr. Algernon Austin and his paper is
titled or his talk is titled xenophobia
Islamophobia racism and the post-racial
presidency it's an honor to be with you
here today so this morning's panel
professor Jacobsen encouraged us to do
deep history and by that he meant that
we should maybe look 400 years in the
past or even even deeper I want to begin
with a shallow history I'm gonna look 9
years into the past to take us to a very
different moment but I think a very
important moment and that was the moment
where when many many people declared
America post-racial when many people
argued that the very issues that we're
discussing today were irrelevant to
understanding contemporary life so so to
take us back to 2008 in 2008 the NPR
news analyst Daniel Schorr argued that
Obama's President Obama he would become
President Obama but Obama's campaign
successes signaled the emergence of a
post-racial era where civil rights
veterans of the past century are
consigned to history and Americans begin
to make race free judgments on who
should lead them the african-american
Harvard University professor Henry Louis
Gates Jr declared the that the election
was the symbolic culmination of the
black freedom struggle the grand
achievement of a great collective dream
the African American journalist Ginetta
Rose Boras in the Washington Post
claimed that with the with Barack
Obama's ascension to the
highest office in the United States most
african-americans feel that we have
arrived as fully equal citizens and one
young Californian woman perhaps put it
best when she argued at this point the
whole race thing is over it doesn't
matter anymore we've transcended it now
we have a black president so clearly we
are not racist so this moment I'm not
gonna dwell too much on it but I think
it really requires much more study and
analysis because it reveals how deeply
how profoundly how widely we
misunderstand racial oppression in
America so I really hope you know in my
book I go into it but I really hope that
we we think how is it possible today
when it seems so obvious that we're not
post-racial how was it possible for so
many people in that moment to believe
that a post-racial America arose so soon
after soon after the election of Barack
Obama it was clear that a lot of hatred
was directed towards him and towards his
family and I suspected another suspected
that racism had a had a role in the
hatred directed towards his family but
not everyone agreed so for example one
presidential historian that I
communicated with he argued that look
every president has been hated by some
segments of the American public and he
he wrote to me Harry Truman was
condemned for being soft on communism
and therefore risking deliverance of
America to Russia Franklin Roosevelt was
called a socialist Thomas Jefferson was
called the Antichrist Andrew Jackson was
called a Caesar over the top criticisms
of presidents has a long history
that was his pushback that the the term
we're using today against my argument
the more conservative act activists
there their response to the charge of
racism against President Obama was along
these lines
so one stated how dare you state that
Republicans are criticizing Barack Obama
because of his race what evidence do you
have of that we judge him by the content
of the of his character not the color of
his skin we criticize him because his
ignorance incompetence and arrogance are
destroying this country the greatest one
on earth so that was you know the the
the various types of responses are
challenges to the notion that racism was
behind at least place to role in the
hatred of Barack Obama so I decided that
I wanted to take on this challenge of
what evidence is there is it simply
there are always gonna be people who
hate the president or is it that people
just don't like his policies you know
and they think he has really terrible
policies and that's why they they hate
him so I turn to the 2012 American
National Election study it's a national
survey that's that's given every
election year to try to answer this
question and I focus in on the the
people with the most intense hatred of
Barack Obama people that I call Obama
haters and in this analysis well there
are multiple parts of this analysis but
one part I took on that first question
the first challenge from that historian
is the this sort of hatred directed at
Barack Obama what we would expect
against any other president so I was
able to compare the Obama haters
individuals is the most intense hatred
of Barack Obama with this is 2012 Mitt
Romney haters people with intense hatred
towards miss Mitt Romney and although
the data set is a quantitative data set
there was some open-ended questions that
allowed some qualitative exploration and
one question that was useful to me was
the question is there anything in
particular about Barack Obama or Mitt
Romney that might make you want to vote
against him
so I looked at the responses from the
Obama haters and the Romney haters to
this questions to get a sense of what
might be motivating them and in this
analysis I found that Mitt Romney was
hated for things that he said and that
he did and Barack Obama was hated for
things that he said and he did but Obama
was also hated for things that had no
basis in reality so for example hater
210 said he's he's a Muslim socialist
and wasn't born in this country he's a
liar and is taking this country down
he's a terrible president hater 301 he's
a communist dictator wannabe who has no
respect for God our history our
Constitution our freedoms our culture
our borders our military our tax money
Israel or the truth and this hater is
not done also he's a pro terrorist
Muslim anti colonialists with an animus
towards whites in general and American
whites in particular he has no love for
this country or its people he's a man to
be feared not respected so what was
interesting in the in the Obama hatred
or the responses from the Obama haters
was that Obama was being hated for being
a socialist which he's not for being a
Muslim which he's not for being an
immigrant which he's not and for trying
to destroy the country which he did not
do so it's worth noting that the Obama
haters although Obama is Christian more
than 60% of Obama haters say that he's
Muslim
and although Obama's American nearly
two-thirds of the Obama haters say that
he's foreign-born so there I saw that
difference between the Obama haters and
the Romney haters people were clearly
throwing ideas and beliefs towards Obama
that that had no basis in reality in the
quantitative research I was able to look
more to try to tease out the issues
around political ideology there I
compared the Obama haters versus a group
of conservatives who while they may not
like Obama very much they didn't have
this deep intense hatred of Barack Obama
and by doing this I'm essentially
controlling for political ideology there
are two conservative groups so when you
find differences between the two groups
that can't be driven by conservatism and
I found in the analysis of Obama haters
Express more dislike towards blacks and
Latinos than conservatives were not
Obama haters Obama haters express more
hostility and resentment towards box
that conservatives were not Obama haters
and in a multivariate analysis I found
that
anti-black attitudes are a significant
predictor of being an Obama hater even
after taking political ideology and and
a number of other factors into account
so so this suggests that there was that
anti black racial prejudice played a
role in the hatred of Barack Obama now
this is what I went into the study
expecting to find that was my suspicion
but as I did this analysis there are
things that that did surprise me that I
did not expect and one thing was what I
called the white victimhood mentality
and that can be explained by this
comment that was made in a New York
Times article and the person wrote a lot
of white people honestly think they have
been significant significantly deprived
of various things because of minorities
and it's hard to overstate how deeply
these feet of feelings run it's not so
much animosity towards people who are
who are different
it's the animosity of the aggrieved they
feel like they are victims and in my
analysis of of this white victimhood
mentality I found that many Obama haters
perceived the United States to be a
country in which whites are an oppressed
minority for many of them White's faced
a great deal of discrimination as much
or more than that faced by
african-americans and Latinos they
believed that whites are politically
disenfranchised group confronting a
country with politically powerful blacks
and Latinos they also believe that the
Obama administration favored blocks over
whites
now this exaggeration of the political
power of blacks and Latinos should
I think it's useful to think of the
history of anti-semitism because what
you see with the history of Nancy
semitism is that the political and
economic power of Jews are exaggerated
claims of victimization by Jews are
popularized and spread and then that is
used as a justification for political
economic and even physical violence
against Jews and we're in a moment where
I believe we're seeing this exaggeration
of political and economic power of
african-americans and Latinos and I
believe that we will see this use as a
justification or I think you can even
find examples today as a justification
for political economic and even physical
attacks on these groups so I think it's
something that we should really pay
attention to and make note of so that's
one thing that surprised me and frankly
I must admit that the the xenophobia and
the Islamophobia that I found also
surprised me I knew that that people
made those statements but I just thought
they were so ridiculous that no one
would take them seriously but over and
over again I I found these expressions
so I had to acknowledge that these are
these are things that that the Obama
haters take seriously so again more than
60% of Obama haters say that Obama is
foreign-born and they say things like
this at hater 34 I don't believe he's an
American I think he's a terrorist
sympathies sympathizer he's selling us
out we are going to have a revolution in
this country right now there are
veterans and we have all fought fought
for our flag we took an oath to protect
our country against all enemies
foreign and domestic hater 246 he's not
from the United States he's lied for
years about a false birth certificate
and he's running our country into the
ground so in the quantitative analysis I
found that Obama haters are more
anti-immigrant than conservatives who
are not Obama haters nearly 90% of Obama
haters want the police to stop and check
the immigration status of anyone they
believed to be undocumented so a strong
endorsement of racial profiling Obama
haters give the lowest support for the
DREAM Act daca that which allows
children brought into the United States
illegally to obtain permanent residency
and in my multivariate analysis here
anti immigrant attitude to strongly
correlated with being an Obama hater
even after controlling for conservatism
and other factors so with Islamophobia
again more than 60% of Obama haters say
Obama is Muslim and they say things like
this hater 558 he's a Muslim and the
proof is all over the place but people
refused to see it if he has to choose
between Americans and Muslims he will
side with his Muslim brethren he has
apologized and kowtow to every nation in
the world that we should be watching
like a hawk so again the the Obama
haters are more anti Muslims and
conservatives were not Obama haters they
were also more likely to describe
Muslims as unpatriotic and violent then
conservatives who are not at Obama
haters the anti-muslim attitudes in the
multivariate analysis was found to be
strongly correlated with being an
Obama hater even after controlling for
conservatism so we've seen that Obama
haters are strongly anti black and many
of them feel that whites are victims of
powerful minority groups Obama's seen as
being out to destroy America and this
view stems from the perception of Obama
as being foreign-born and Muslim for
Obama haters immigrants are a threat to
the American Way of life and Muslims are
seen as being violent and anti-american
and therefore by seeing Obama as
foreign-born and Muslim they attach
those qualities to him
so overall although I do this all this
analysis around Barack Obama I'm really
using him just as a case study although
he's been subject to xenophobia
Islamophobia and racism he's been very
successful and will likely continue to
be so so my main concern really is for
people not named Barack Obama people of
color not named Obama Barack Obama who
don't have Obama's many advantages
just a reminder mama was raised by a
white mother and white grandparents who
were able to get him enrolled in an
elite private school in Hawaii he did
not experience the disadvantage of
growing up in a poor black community he
has two degrees from Ivy League
universities and in the words of Joe
Biden he's articulate and bright and
clean and a nice looking guy in spite of
all these positive qualities he's still
being subject to extreme hatred if this
occurs with Obama
what should we assume can occur with an
average black person who does not have
his many advantages the somewhat good
news is that Obama haters represents
only about 10% of the Amer
an electorate however they are far more
powerful than their numbers suggests
because there are more they are more
likely to vote in primaries and caucuses
they are more likely to contact their
political representatives and they are
more likely to donate to political
campaigns compared to other Americans
because of these things they have much
more political power than their numbers
and my preliminary analysis suggests
that about half of Obama haters are also
Trump lovers you know they express
strong intense support for Donald Trump
but regardless Trump lovers are also
intensely the preliminary preliminary
analysis suggests intensely xenophobic
Islamophobic and racists and we saw
professor whinin had a slide up from a
newspaper with the headline Trump voters
thinks White's Christians most oppressed
groups in the United States so we see
that that white victimhood mentality
among the Trump supporters Trump Obama
haters and Trump lovers combined make up
nearly 20% of the American electorate so
in addition to this the strong hateful
force in the electorate we should also
be concerned because there's a social
sociological theory that predict but as
a minority group grows in size there's
likely to be more competition and
conflict so as America becomes more
diverse there's reason to expect that
there will be more racial conflict and
more ethnic animosity this means that
those of us who wish to avoid more
hatred more conflict and more political
dysfunction need to work hard against
these forces unfortunately there is no
quick solution we did not get to where
we are today overnight so I'll go back
to Professor Jacobson there is a deep
history to where we are today
and we will not be able to reverse where
the trends that we're seeing overnight
we will need to organize and be active
for decades the hopeful news is that we
have seen that the hatred of Obama is
based the significantly on
misinformation the Obama haters are
convinced that Obama's mission was to
destroy America and to oppress white
people much of the hatred of people of
color is similarly based in
misinformation this means that a
sustained campaign challenging this
misinformation has the potential to be
successful in reducing racial and ethnic
conflict thank you
[Music]